that guy looks like the boy dynamite the
one next one yeah that one looks like
the point dynamite that's as close as
we're going I do not think I know the
nineties at all I think I'm gonna do
terrible no I excited for this oh gosh
the nineties you people I think I know
more than him
I don't think I know a lot but I know
more than him yeah I don't know if I'm
gonna know any I might be able to name
one but let's see what happens
Wow like one of those boy bands all
right like boys to men Backstreet Boys
am i close my in the ballpark first
thing that popped in my head was the
Beach Boys but I'm fairly certain that's
wrong i I have no clue I think I know it
yeah I know it
Backstreet Boys or NSYNC one of the two
I think
okay yeah that was my first guess I've
never even heard of them in sync
this is insane
I knew it was a boy band but he looks
familiar
curly-haired that's Justin Timberlake
yes that's Justin no you're lying to me
I did not know that so much better now
oh god yeah she also looks familiar
I don't know her name first guest that I
would have to give I know it's
completely wrong kind of reminds me of
Kelly Clarkson don't like her lipstick
friends I know her from blended also
blended yeah the one with a Adamson Adam
Sandler and Terry Crews can't they were
named I have no who
yeah there's no chance of me and I don't
know the actor sad I mean I'd be my
guest but it's also probably ya know
you're probably right there yeah that
just seems like a boy that would be in a
heart yeah he definitely looks like you
the gate is like I talked to ghostwrite
or home alone I don't know it's the the
ghost kid right 6x6 success yeah that's
a boy band they all like posing like
they're in a boy band like a really bad
album cover I'm also gonna say Beach
Boys I know it's wrong I know the thing
yeah that or some another random 90s
movies I was noticing oystermen
Backstreet Boys
yeah I already said in sync okay who's
been Backstreet Boys
is it Backstreet Boys I was thinking of
that why didn't I say cuz that's the
only thing I know of but I was like oh
maybe it's only from like 2000 dang it I
knew that if I seen them I've seen he's
been in my movies lately but I can't
think of his name or any movie yeah he
looks like he's like a sitcom star maybe
he kinda looks like the guy who played a
really Wonka one boy like a little bit
that smiles a little weird I have no
clue who that is this is a prob you read
I've heard the name before seen her face
oh my gosh it's so familiar I've
definitely seen a movie or show she's in
I know what you did laughing oh I've
only heard that I like in a reference
like Pablo to reference it I've never
seen out of him I've heard the name
before no she looks like a young version
of someone I know now I feel like a
theater oh I don't know wow she's so
mean but yeah no I understand what
you're saying and I completely agree
he's very familiar I don't know who she
was the movie ocean's 8 she wasn't she
was you're gonna hate me for asking this
because that the girl from the bird box
movie I'm so sad that's like how I know
her because I know I should know her as
like oh she's a lot better roles but
Sandra Bullock I'm feeling good about
myself today
Oh Sandra boy she's an accountant I have
no idea that is I haven't even like seen
that before
seems like a Mike Mike or an Adam this
is Princeton so I wasn't even close
yeah he's he's a lot you don't know who
that is
she's either an actress or a model or
dancer she seems very like fit and
athletic I have no idea I don't want to
just like sit here and stare at the
photo I don't know this seems like a cop
show like good cop bad cop but the good
cop is the guy and the bad cop is the
girl and they're about to Gillick
infiltrate a home
[Music]
crimes ok crime scenes this crime scene
investigation done done you know like
the crime shows law and order no wait
that was the done to show saw BuzzFeed
unsolved ok I was getting there it's
still on its own here it's on the air
but it's like completely rebooted I've
never I really feel like I'm 13 right
now yeah why people just never seen
before my life he's an actor kind of
looks annoying but I don't know who he
is is it Justin Timberlake again no you
really up said if you guys were told
that one on me he was JT really Cinnabon
symbol related to you how am I related
to you I know this one
I've seen it before god I'd known a guy
from multiple movies middle I can't
leave his name yeah the guy in the front
seems like that annoying looking kid
from before
[Music]
it's also Tim Allen is the voice of Buzz
Light here oh yeah
in the Santa Clause yeah have you seen
the Santa Clause no in Bad Santa that
movies funny yeah I know she is
I can't leave her name but I can
probably fit looks familiar that's been
an something recent she played a mom in
some show mom I can't I know exactly god
I can't think of a show or movie
she played Veronica and Heather's wow
that's right
yes I have what not a writer
she wasn't Heather's right yeah I like
her she started as a mom in strangers
name that's right oh but she is like
such short hair yeah that's awesome we
did it
how are you feeling yeah pretty well
awful I'm surprised I knew at least one
person apparently I knew the characters
more than I knew the actors I don't way
better than I thought I was going to oh
I died and it awful okay let's go I
thought I would do so much better I
didn't know any names I recognize so
many people I wanted to like really
cheese and you'd be like we all build
over time and it's good to learn about
our past but like do I care
No
[Music]